[Music]
we're going to show you our hey but I'm
still living the upper east side of this
pretty dope spot we pay about 1500 and
rent which to steal the place you're
gonna see so come on in clothing
building is our landlord but in some
electronic locks recently that were a
Bluetooth number Street when I haven't
front of me but there's barely a couple
of times I'm at one percent battery and
like rushing home at 4 a.m. right as you
enter the apartment and it's kitchen
that I share with the three other
college friends that I live with in this
apartment we're all trying to come a
little bit and like split up time in
terms of who gets to cook when it's
really crazy for New York is that we
have this dishwasher right here you
don't see that a lot this is like a
thing to show up like them now friends
over it's like how yeah the dishwasher
in New York others a little excessive
we got a wine cooler we didn't even
drink a lot of wine so I gotta know we
use this for but it just looks really
dope so it's pretty nice
[Music]
so see
all right to my bedroom I guess you
could say huh this is where the magic
happens
it's not too big it's pretty cozy I'm
not gonna find a lot of big bedrooms in
New York so I'm lucky with what I have
here I really wish I had space for a
desk or something um but I kind of like
make do with this like bookshelf that's
like a standing desk you can't tell
already from the guitar the wall like
all the other stuff ruling it music so
this also doubles as my home studio
sometimes I just kind of like put my mic
in the closet to kind of soundproof in
my laptop you record music too sometimes
sounds like nice access to the fire
escape outside spend dream of mine to
serenade a lady out there it doesn't
happen looking for the right one but
maybe someday my favorite things the
room is at the wall of album art and I
have up here plunge to my my favorite
album Saturday wake up that's the first
thing I see I can kind of just like
throw on one of those albums kind of
morning as I'm getting ready for work
make do with what I got still a nice
sitting in the freeway got the TV over
here this aren't bad his-and-her sneaks
nice wide mirror nice brown rugs with a
black shower curtain fascias bathtub
warning the bathrooms kind of small so
now you expect in like most places
especially like somewhere in my mid west
or the south
New York is it's really small this is
what you get you know everything's gonna
cramp together it's also not just mine I
share it with with one other person
constantly competing for a shower time
in the morning we're trying to make it
work and it's not too bad right here
hang out here eat together an impossible
or just kind of like get some work done
we have that explode pretty much there's
definitely a staple of any hipster vibe
in any New York apartment there's an
extra bedroom in this apartment that we
kind of converted into a living room so
we got a couch here we have our TV got
some video games this is where we all
hang out we have people over we're
supposed to fit comfortably in this
couch like five or six people but we've
had like 15 20 people in here before we
squeezed and we made it work
glass table TV with a PS cords and video
games
what are those surprising things about
this apartment again you don't find this
in New York that often so you got a
backyard in the summer we've had some
parties before sometimes projected
movies on that wall
kind of weird thing about our Hartmann
is you have this like giant beautiful
window here or dining room
I stood right at a brick wall I think no
sunlight so that's like New York
[Music]
we'll invite people but it makes you
look like you're biking somewhere so you
don't get bored while you're exercising
motivates you
[Music]
going into here you can see this is the
small area right here so right here this
is our gym this is only have you ever
pull-up bar take it down there's some
push-ups and pull-ups we don't really
have a gym in this apartment building or
anything so this is when we got cheapest
remember shape this is our pool area BAM
we actually have two floors of argot two
of our bedrooms are upstairs other two
guys live downstairs and this is where
it gets really special again New York
you don't see this all the time we have
our own laundry and dryer this is when
we show P what people visit us and
people come over this is how we impress
them
so like you don't have this apartment in
New York for 1500 a it's a super writer
to get that wash your honor to the
dishwasher and although it's not a lot
of space likes for guys and a lot people
over frequently we make it work and we
have a pretty good time so thanks again
for checking it out and hope to see you
in New York
thanks for checking out our apartment if
you live in Houston you can get great
amenities tons of space and the stress
free by
[Music]